6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish, I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil.
When Helen Russell was three years old, her newborn baby sister died suddenly.
Looking back at that sad time, Helen remembers making a big decision.
She wanted to be happy.
She became a best-selling author and wrote a book called The Atlas of Happiness.
She got married and even moved to the famously happy city of Copenhagen in Denmark.
But the sadness Helen felt didn't disappear.
And the longer she lived abroad, the more she wondered whether her feelings were somehow
connected to being born in England, into a culture where, traditionally, expressing your
emotions was discouraged.
In this programme, we'll be investigating how the way people express sadness is influenced
by their culture.
And as usual, we'll be learning some new useful vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Neil.
In English, there are many idioms which describe being sad, including down in the dumps,
meaning that you feel miserable and depressed.
Also, emotions are often associated with colours.
For example, you might go red with anger or turn green with envy.
But which colour is associated with sadness?
Is it A, yellow, B, blue or C, brown?
I think the answer is blue.
Ok, Neil, we'll find out later in the programme.
Around the world, cultures express emotions very differently.
In Spain, flamenco performers express their emotions with colourful displays of song
and dance, whereas in Japan, crying is considered weak and shameful.
To discover more about how British people express their feelings, Helen Russell interviewed
Thomas Dixon, a professor at the Centre for the History of Emotion for BBC World Service
programme The Documentary
The word sad, as you will know, Helen, literally means satire or full.
So it's earliest uses in English.
It means being literally fed up, being full of something sad or say it means heavy and full.
And then of course we have this huge vocabulary of melancholy, sorrow, grief, depression,
and many many other terms and they all mean slightly different things.
Professor Dixon explains that the original meaning of the word sad was full or fed up.
A phrase which today means being unhappy, bored or tired of something which has been going
on for a long time.
For example, everyone is fed up of Covid.
But fed up is just one of many words to describe feelings of sadness, each with a slightly
different meaning.
One of them is melancholy, a kind of intense and thoughtful sadness.
Another is grief, a strong sadness often caused by the death of someone you love.
In Irish culture, melancholy is expressed artistically in poems or songs and in other cultures,
India, for example, grief can be expressed by professional mourners who are paid to cry
by the family of the person who has died.
In England, however, big public displays of emotion are uncommon.
But according to Professor Dixon, that wasn't always the case.
Here he explains to BBC World Service programme the documentary, how it was only quite recently
during the time of Queen Victoria and the British Empire, that the English got a reputation
for being repressed and able to show their true feelings and emotions.
By and large, it's a Victorian and then it's an audience and 20th century characterisation.
As you can imagine, you know it fits with the era of empire, of white British men going
around the world, conquering it and having a stiff upper lip and ruling over the people
in other parts of the world and believing themselves, the white Europeans to be superior,
one sign of that superiority in Darwin writes,
English men rarely cry except under the pressure of the acuteest grief.
Professor Dixon says that the Victorians who ran the British Empire had a stiff upper lip.
These men believed they were better than everyone else and that to cry was a sign of weakness.
When we cry, our top lip starts to wobble and so this gave rise to the idiom a stiff upper lip,
meaning to not show your feelings when you're upset even though it's difficult not to.
Fortunately, most Brits are less repressed nowadays, but it's still hard for some people,
especially men, to express their feelings.
Sometimes drinking alcohol gives people the courage to say what they're feeling,
but this is not so healthy and can even increase feelings of depression.
It's talking to someone about your feelings that can really help and keep away the blues
and in saying that, I think I've answered your question, Sam.
I asked Neil which colour is often associated with feeling sad?
And I said it was blue.
Which was, of course, the correct answer.
And it gives us another idiom about sadness, feeling blue.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this programme
about the emotion of sadness, or in other words, feeling down in the dumps.
If you are fed up of something, you're unhappy, bored or tired of it,
especially if it's been happening a long time.
Melancholy is a type of intense and thoughtful sadness,
while grief is a strong sadness usually caused by someone's death.
The adjective repressed means unable to show your true feelings and emotions.
And finally, the uniquely British idiom to keep a stiff upper lip
means not to show your feelings when you're upset.
Even though it is difficult not to.
Hiding your feelings definitely won't make you happy,
but making friends and learning something new might.
So remember to join us again soon here at 6 Minute English.
Bye for now.
Goodbye.